as Europe gets ready for a cold winter
Vladimir Putin is defiant at this
economic Forum in Russia's Far East he
blamed the West entirely for creating
the energy crisis through sanctions
they put themselves in this situation
and don't know what to do now they
painted themselves into a sanctioned
corner there's only one way out of this
but sanctions won't be lifted whilst
Russia continues to bomb residential
areas in a war that shows no sign of
ending
this was what's left of a block of flats
in kharkif even as his forces struggled
to make military gains Vladimir Putin
denied his invasion was failing
I am sure that we've not lost anything
and will not lose anything regarding
Acquisitions I can say that the main
acquisition is the strengthening of our
sovereignty and this is the result of
what is happening now
sitting on a panel with the leaders of
Myanmar and Mongolia and members of the
Chinese leadership this was a chance to
play Down the impact of the conflict on
Russia's economy and standing in the
world it comes after Mr Putin oversaw
war games involving Russian and Chinese
troops
foreign
is needed that the Kremlin is continuing
its pivot towards Asia
and the new prime minister Liz truss who
visited Moscow Before the War when
diplomacy was still a word was also
singled out
in the UK the procedure for electing the
head of state is far from democratic the
UK people do not participate in the
change of government in this case the
comments here were very much aimed at an
audience that's either on Russia's side
or is yet to make up its mind in Europe
leaders already know what they think and
as the continent braces itself for
spiraling Energy prices the EU
commission is planning a price cap on
Russian gas
there will be more hardship to come as
the new Cold War deepens
Alex Rossi Sky News